et bien bonjour à toutes et à tous ici
argot rock comme vous le savez ça fait
un moment à 22h04 est sorti et je vous
avais proposé un sondage sur ce dernier
et du coup vous avez été 1695 à répondre
ça fait extrêmement plaisir vous êtes
toujours de plus en plus à répondre au
sondage ça me touche énormément
d'ailleurs le prochain sondage est déjà
disponible dans la description donc je
vous conseille d'aller le voir et d'y
répondre
c'est un sondage un petit peu
particulier cette fois-ci vous allez
voir mais qui est tout aussi intéressant
et puis du coup on va commencer sans
tarder et du coup voyons voir vos
réponses je vous avoue je me souviens
même plus des questions ça fait un
moment que je suis pas allé voir ce
sondage
[Musique]
alors question toute bête du coup mais
est-ce que vous avez aimé avengers
infinity ward oui c'est le meilleur film
du mc où vous êtes 70% à le penser
oui j'ai bien aimé non sans plus non pas
du tout ah ouais y'a quand même vraiment
ah oui d'accord vous êtes quand même
c'est incroyable ce film est vraiment le
film va enfin genre ça a été un succès
total en fait et surtout comparé en fait
c'est énorme et on le remarque très
facilement par exemple avec la sortie de
star wars 8 star wars qui est une
licence une saga très attendu très
connue très apprécié par tout le monde a
extrêmement divisé les foules et comparé
à une finity voir infinity ward a été
une claque interplanétaire
internationale je veux dire pardon et du
coup genre tu as ce film a été vraiment
incroyable que ce soit visuellement
scénaristiquement il a été utilisé
depuis un bon moment aux puces et comme
star wars star wars en plus je compare
facilement star wars parce que le savoir
on était hype est aussi depuis un bon
moment et là c'est pareil ça fait
extrêmement de tan tan hausse et tease
et au final il ya aucun défaut que tu es
vraiment incroyable tout est parfait ce
film est franchement une traque essayé
pour moi clairement le meilleur film du
mcg
[Musique]
alors passons directement la question 2
du coup alors là par contre va y avoir
du taf
quel est votre héros préféré du mc eu ça
a été très compliqué j'ai mis tous les
héros je me suis dit voilà c'est une
question un peu intéressante donc avoir
écouté docteur strange 17% tort 17% à 6
30 g devant iron man et quand même
iron man est premier suivi de strange et
de thor puis de spider man et spider man
à ce point là et captain america
je me disais bien aussi donc du coup ce
serait iron man en un docteur strange en
2 thor en trois tailles dorman en quatre
captain america en cinq blacks panthère
en six stars lors dans cette sorcière
rouge en 8
et puis après ça devient trop petit
moment évidemment à chaque fois je le
dis mais c'est dr strange sans hésiter
subi de captain america je pense et
subite toronto 3 ça serait ça strange
captain america et thor c'est vraiment
les persos j'apprécie de plus dr strange
franchement et c'est lui qui m'a fait
redécouvrir marc marvel j'ai franchement
sur qui fait cette plus originale est
l'un des héros les plus puissants plus
rien à dire de plus quoi
[Musique]
question 3 comment avez vous trouvé
thanos badass américain parfait génial
incroyable puissants super excellent
vient charismatique badass génial
parfait incroyable calmons nous
monstrueux cool humain c'est vrai au
fond c'est vrai que c'est marant il y a
un truc est flagrant quand je dis tout
ça je ne lis aucun défaut dano s'est
appréciée par tout le monde et
franchement c'est mon cas aussi tanoh
c'est vraiment incroyable
c'est ça la force en fait de ce film
c'est que comparé à tous les autres
méchants voilà les méchants il c'est des
méchants ils font des trucs parce qu'ils
sont méchants et c'est la noce
il a quand même une raison de faire ce
qu'il fait et elle est légitime en fait
on comprend pourquoi il fait ça au final
il a eu raison sur titan là quand il
avait prévenu tout le monde et qu'il
fallait faire une sorte de purge etc
c'était carrément de la folie mais au
final il avait raison la planète titans
et au final déserte est complètement
détruite et là j'ai eu trop peur jean
teulé quelqu'un tousse et jeu de la
boule pousse la porte de la légitimité à
tout ça et le fait qu'ils pleurent aussi
pour gamme or a approfondi son côté
humain côté qu'on n'avait pas l'habitude
de voir dans ta n'ose pas ce que vous
allez en même temps c'est très compliqué
de s'associer à un personnage qui est
c'est un extraterrestre même si les
humanoïdes il n'est pas vraiment c'est
pas un humain quoi donc on ne sait pas
s'il a les mêmes sentiments etc
et du coup ça nous fait réellement
apprécié la noce et c'est franchement
l'un des meilleurs méchants que j'ai
jamais vu
monde du cinéma très clairement
[Musique]
alors du coup question 4 je voulais
vraiment avoir votre avis là-dessus
parce que du coup j'en ai parlé dans
quelques vidéos théorie infinity ward
possède une fin très tragique pour les
avengers qui va vraiment sauver la
situation pour vous en tuant thanos
captain marvel est premier avec 40%
c'est logique en fait captain marvel et
le héros qu'est teasé à la fin de
avengers infinity ward avec la scène
post générique et voilà c'est cette
scène qui est censé expliquer comment va
se passer la suite en fait du coup le
film le dit lui même que c'est captain
america qui va ramener la situation en
fait enfin moi je le comprend ainsi
personnellement adam warlock les mimes
et évidemment adam warlock ne fera pas
partie des avengers 4 pour ceux qui ne
savent pas désolé pour vous tort
évidemment tort un gros rôle à jouer
après est-ce qu'il sera vraiment au
combat en fait c'est ça le truc je pense
que oui il voudra toujours tuer thanos
de ce qu'ils vivent vraiment eu et or
révèle enfin sa puissance une vraie
puissance phénoménale et il est même
certainement le plus fort des avengers
du coup d'or va avoir un très gros rôle
mais le truc c'est que ceux qui ne
savent pas d'un jeune sur quatre y aura
apparemment des survivants à ce gardien
il y aura aussi walkyrie du coup tort ce
ne sera peut-être pas forcément combat
mais sera plus à prêter main forte pour
les asgardiens et les protéger les
derniers les autres gardiens et dernier
avengers bah évidemment il y aura
normalement une scène avec tous les
avengers réunies et il ya toujours les
dernières bonnes choses qui sont
bizarrement les premiers avengers qui
qui étaient là en premier je pense que
ce n'est pas fait pour rien même si une
fine d'ivoire possède une fin tragique
et qu'on sait évidemment que tous les
héros vont revenir
il y aura forcément des morts il y aura
forcément des sacrifices aux autres et
comme bons nombres le pense
captain america nous quittera forcément
moi j'en suis sûr et certain il est
possible que black widow par exemple
meurtre est clairement les coûts des
opus est prévu un spin off sur helpe est
un spin off sur son passé sur comment
elle est devenue comme ça et c est
justement là ce serait qu'elle partirait
à ce moment-là avengers 4 pareil pour
boca qui reviendra en revenant mais
voilà c'est il ya quand même une grosse
différence par exemple entre les
nouveaux avengers qui arrivent de plus
en plus chaque jour et par exemple aux
cayes et natacha c'est vraiment des
personnages en plus et surtout vu la
phase iv qui va arriver on en reparlera
dans une autre vidéo mais vu la phase iv
qui va arriver
ils vont très vite perdre pied très
clairement servent juste en fait de
personnages auxquels on peut se
rattacher nous en tant qu'humain parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de superpouvoirs ils
sont à peu près comme nous ont juste des
grosses facultés et voilà quoi il pareil
pour banner banner j'ai pas ce qu'ils
prévoient de faire avec lui mais soit il
va devenir surpuissant soit ils vont
totalement le fait en fait parce que joe
banner il devient de plus en plus ça
devient de plus en plus une blague à
chaque film j'ai l'impression banner ne
sert à rien d'en avengers 3 et c'est à
se demander s'ils veulent le dégager ou
si en fait c'est pour qu'ils fassent une
grosse apparition un gros rôle dans
avengers 4 ce qui pourrait être fort
possible surtout qu'il est
il pourrait porter le gant de l'infini
largement
[Musique]
alors question 5 aviez vos lui les
comics avant de voir le film si oui est
ce une bonne adaptation non je n'ai pas
lu les comics vous êtes 80% je pense que
c'est la majorité d'entre nous
évidemment moi non plus je n'ai pas lu
les communes je vous l'avouer que ça ne
sert pas vraiment pour les films on va
dire et surtout c'est comme chaque film
à succès voilà la majorité n'ont pas lu
les livres avant de voir les films donc
ça ne m'étonne pas du tout en tout cas
pour ceux qui ont lu les livres vous
êtes majoritairement à dire que
l'adaptation est très bonne mais que
voilà le film est bien mais ne
respectent en rien les comics ce qui
n'est pas étonnant voilà les films sont
obligés d'adapter certaines choses pour
que ça soit rendue au mieux au cinéma
que une certaine cohérence dans parle
souvent avec le personnage de la mort
dont tanoh cet amoureux c'est compliqué
de faire intervenir un personnage qui
est complètement genre la mort en fait
qui est là qui est dame nature qui est
la mort et qui apparaissent comme ça en
tant que personnage à qui on peut botter
les fesses etc
enfin c'est toujours un petit peu
délicat donc ça ne m'étonne pas très
franchement
[Musique]
je devais être obligé de la pause et en
fait si vous deviez posséder une seule
pierre d'infinité laquelle serait-ce
évidemment une personne sur deux
aimeraient la pierre du temps mais en
même temps c'est la pierre qui monte
quand même le plus d'utilité dans les
films et qui impressionne le plus
techniquement parce qu'on a envoy
docteur strange remonter le temps etc
thanos pareil et franchement moi je
pense est la pire que je voudrais aussi
très clairement 22 % voire la pire la
réalité ouais je vois pas trop trop
l'utilité en soi mais pourquoi pas en
même temps si je vois un petit peu ce
pourquoi pas et enfin la pierre de
l'espace
ouais mais c'est vrai que la pierre du
temps et font ce que tout le monde
voudrait c'est là on va dire la pierre
la plus accessible et celle avec qui on
voit le sait ce qu'on peut faire avec en
fait très clairement
[Musique]
alors question c'est de jouer vraiment
posé cette question parce que comme je
disais thanos avait vraiment un
personnage incroyable il a franchement
un fonds incroyable et france 5
personnages extrêmement travaillée son
but d'éradiquer la moitié des habitants
de chaque planète pour éviter sa
destruction et légitime en fait l'acte
pour la nature en fête et pour la
bienveillance du monde mais en même
temps ce qui fait totalement horrible
est totalement inhumain c'est
inconcevable de faire tout ça moi après
inhumain ça correspond pas à la noce
puisqu'il n'est pas humain justement
mais est ce que vous comprenez son but
c'est ça la question en fait oui mais tu
es tellement de gens et inhumain voilà
vous êtes trois quarts à penser ceci fut
totalement d'accord avec vous évidemment
vous êtes quand même 13 % à penser que
non ils justaret ils veulent pouvoir qui
est vrai en même temps est ce qui est
malheureusement je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez mais moi c'est quelque chose
que je trouve qui gâche beaucoup de
films le méchant possède un but très
précis tout d'un coup on remarque qu'en
fait il ya un truc qui se cache derrière
et qui en fait montre que c'est juste un
méchant qui veut faire des trucs de
méchants etc
je trouve ça gâche vraiment la chose et
j'espère thanos c'est pas ça parce que
je sais qu'ils veulent pouvoir je sais
qu'il veut devenir une sorte de dieu
mais son but est vraiment légitime est
incroyable et j'espère que ça sera pas
gâché avec oui c'est en fait c'est juste
un méchant qui veut faire des trucs de
méchants et qui du coup cacher sa
méchanceté avec un but de gentillesse
voilà je détesterais ça
[Musique]
alors du coup qu'ils sont en vie dont je
me souviens même plus si vous deviez tué
six héros pour détruire les six pierre
d'infini tu es un héros par pierre et
donc éviter ce massacre lesquels
seraient utiles vous foutez de ma gueule
ou quoi les mecs
aucun je sais pas je ne sais pas je sais
pas alors ça c'est ceux qui ont eu la
flemme
je ne sais pas aucun je ne sais pas tu
as vous êtes sérieux la majorité des
réponses et vous embêter les couilles
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vous foutez
de moi ou quoi alors moi je vous fais
des sondages et tout et vous me répondez
je sais pas je n'en sais rien a [ __ ]
chanel à [ __ ] allez quand même des
gens qui ont répondu vision les gardiens
la galaxie les premiers avengers ryan un
cas il y en a quand même deux qui ont
répondu et la même chose est très
clairement chaud trop dur ah ben moi je
pose des grosses questions un cd
question qui amène à la réflexion là
désolé mec peuvent pas dire trop triste
en fait c'est morose que cette question
en fait révèle les personnages que vous
n'aimez pas en fait
pour ceux qui se sont donné les moyens
ça révèle les personnages que vous
n'aimez pas d'accord donc la majorité
reste quand même vision ou war machine
black widow ça reste à peu près ça
généralement et trax monteith par
exemple des personnages un petit peu
secondaire des gardiens de la galaxie
autres moi personnellement si j'avais
tué six héros bat black widow la captain
america même si c'est un de mes préférés
parce que je suis sûr qu'il partira war
machine évidemment ski aux cayes
bareille hawkeye jeu pas très grand fan
de hockey et je trouve pas qu'il est
très très utile monteith pareil ou drax
sincèrement ça c'est une question pas
facile je remercie ceux qui ont vraiment
pris la peine et le temps de répondre à
cette question parce que c'est toujours
plus plaisant à lire que des je sais pas
[Musique]
alors question 9 alors ça c'est
justement comparé à star wars neuf comme
un rat star wars 8 pardon comme on en
parlait est-ce que la haye pas été bien
entretenu parce que star wars et
énormément de heim est vraiment
énormément énormément énormément et au
final tout le monde enfin à tout le
monde mais une grande majorité a été
déçu parce qu'il avait une trop grande
hype et l'eyefinity voir c'est pareil
tout le monde était grave hype et moi
j'étais comme un dingue que j'étais
grève hype et au final j'ai pas été déçu
du tout et vous du coup qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé avec votre cas il a
été bien entretenue entretenu tanoh
c'est quand même utilisé depuis plus de
dix ans maintenant alors je me suis
gouré
je sais que ces cinq six ans apparemment
et du coup oui je n'ai pas été déçu du
tout vous êtes 97% le penser et ce qui
est totalement énorme 97%
c'est dingue ses limites oui à l'unisson
en fait il ya quasiment fin genre à diac
3% non et là vous êtes 97% à ne pas être
déçu du tout comme quoi marvel est
vraiment très fort et extrêmement bien
géré c'est incroyable
[Musique]
alors quelles sont vos attentes pour
avengers quête du coup dernière question
un bon film évidemment adam warlock mais
il n'y sera pas malheureusement le
retour des morts va évidemment captain
marvel c'est pareil c'est évident
j'aimerais voir un peu plus captain
america et voir le rôle qu'auront ant
man et un oeil de faucon grands absents
d'avengers infinity ward pas ça il faut
le savoir en fait c'est que tous les
personnages qui sont absents dean finity
war seront dans avengers cat et auront
forcément un rôle plutôt conséquent
quand même je pense hartmann coup
captain marvel hulk aucun revenu en run
un docteur strange je pense que on va en
entendre encore parler franchement les
personnages qu'ils n'apparaissent pas
dans une force 3 une finity war vous
inquiétez pas à vous les verrez dans
infinity norman george iv en fait
introduire adam warlock vous êtes
vraiment beaucoup apprécié la dame noire
look peut-être pourquoi pas faire une
vidéo sera d'abord un look ça pourrait
être stylé mais du coup vous êtes
beaucoup apprécié à d'un mois à loc
alors du coup c'est vrai que là on les
attend tous au tournant à 20h03 était
incroyable mais avengers 4 est
normalement encore plus gros est encore
plus important puisqu'il va être le
point final la conclusion de phase iii
du mc eu avec des personnages qui
devrait normalement partir d'autres qui
devraient arriver parce qu'il y aura la
7e pierre par exemple des pierres
d'infinité quels personnages vont
disparaître ou est ce que va nous
emmener la phase 4 à être franchement un
avengers incroyable et le troisième a
déjà énormément conquis convaincu
franchement je suis devenu fan
on est clairement dans l'ère des super
héros actuels
en 2018 on est dans l'ère des super
héros ça n'a jamais été autant à la mode
et au temps incroyable et tout ça grâce
à marvell et je suis très enchantés et
très heureux de pouvoir vous faire des
vidéos là dessus et vous soyez au rendez
vous parce que ça me fait plaisir de
pouvoir parler d'eux
de plusieurs choses et que vous fassiez
confiance là dessus du coup je vous
remercie sincèrement je pense qu'on va
arrêter la vidéo là du coup le prochain
sondage est déjà disponible dans la
description je vous fais des gros bisous
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter à
vous abonner à la chaîne s'était argot
rock et que le lie au nord soit avez
vous allez ciao tout
[Musique]